ali reza first of all congratulations
what a dominating performance you came
uh to st luis you said this is a dream
for you to play in st louis not only
that you fulfilled that dream but in
such a tremendous fashion describe to us
your uh feelings right now
yeah actually um
i could reveal a secret it was my
promise for a long time that if i come
to san diego's i win my first tournament
so
i managed to make that promise to myself
for a long time so
now it's really remarkable this um chess
club i'm really in love with this chess
club um
i think everything is
in a
good
manner and i'm really happy to be here
we saw you pensive in between rounds you
were thinking not necessarily speaking
to other players were you just like
simply focused were you trying to be in
the moment
yeah i think um
okay the talking that they were doing it
was also not in a not very important in
the
subject i was not really interested in
so
um
also i think hikora was not talking to
everybody so yeah i think keeping focus
is important so
at least for me so yeah
how important uh was it for your mom to
be here with you in st louis as well as
your brother it felt like they kept you
grounded could you describe that yeah my
whole family is here my father brother
mother everybody's here
um
yeah i always travel with them during
the tournaments so i'm really grateful
for them to be here always with me it's
very important i think
and yeah i'm very thankful
the first time uh being a full-time
player in the grand chess tour and you
already win
an event what does that mean to you yeah
it means a lot of course
it's a very tough tournament
i think this rapidem blitz was the
strongest because the others they were
many few wild cards that were not in
very high rated so
i'm happy to win this one but of course
still there is stingfield cup so
were you aware by uh the fact that with
this last victory you passed 2 900 on
the live waiting list were you keeping
in touch yeah it was a very but the sad
thing is that i'm not number one
imagine the world that you're in 2900
and you're not number one it's well
hikaru won a lot of games as well yes i
thought he chorus should his rating
collapsed during in the middle because
he lost two three games but
i guess his rating was very high so
what an impressive uh performance ali
reza congratulations guys any questions
yeah i wanted to champion from behind
the wall i want to maybe ask alireza to
settle this for us if you wanted if you
had to choose between
i don't know i'm choosing two which i
think are probably in the running there
which one means more to you this one or
the grand swiss
ah
okay um it's very different because
grand swiss was a 20 days event and it
was during quarantine so that was very
important for me also here i think for
now this is more important for me than
grants is because
the cycle of candidates is not the
ideal way so i think this this one means
a lot to me actually maybe this one more
even than currencies
yasser any follow-up questions yeah i
just want to say our deepest
congratulations we you thrilled us
throughout and uh
you're a very deserving champion olivier
is a very good luck to you in the sink
field cup we'll be watching well played
thanks sir congratulations ali reza you
are the champion of the st louis rapid
and blitz congratulations